One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
我和家人最喜欢做的事情之一就是去公路旅行。我们是公路旅行爱好者。乔什和我喜欢收拾好车，带着孩子们出发。我非常喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。我们还喜欢使用Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里，喜欢有厨房，有某种后院或露台，晚上可以坐在那里。
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
我喜欢它的私密性。而且，即使你在冒险，也会感觉像在家里一样，因为你可以营造出自己的家。你知道，Airbnb对家庭来说真的很棒，因为你可以真正选择一个适合你们整个团体的住处。你知道，有一年我和我的家人就是这样做的。
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. Hello. Hi there.
我们都在山里聚会，选了一个很棒的Airbnb，大家住在一起。表亲、侄子侄女、外甥外甥女，还有叔叔阿姨。那真的太有趣了，而且非常温馨。Airbnb确实让那次家庭记忆变得特别。所以，下次冒险时也试试Airbnb吧。你好。嗨。
Okay. We have some really exciting news today. next adventure. Hello! Hi there! Okay, we have some really exciting news to share. We do, Jenna, tell them. All right, my husband Lee Kirk is directing a movie called New Year's Rev and me and Angela both have parts in it. We do, I'm so excited! Tell them what it's about. Okay, well this is a story that he wrote with Billy Joe Armstrong of Green Day, because you know Billy Joe starred in Lee's movie Ordinary World.
好的。我们今天有一些非常令人兴奋的消息。下次冒险。你好！嗨！好的，我们有一些非常令人兴奋的消息要分享。是的，珍娜，告诉他们。好的，我的丈夫李·柯克正在导演一部名为《新年复仇》(New Year's Rev)的电影，我和安吉拉在里面都有角色。我们确实有，我太兴奋了！告诉他们这是关于什么的。好的，这是一个他与绿日乐队的比利·乔·阿姆斯特朗共同创作的故事，因为你知道比利·乔曾主演过李的电影《平凡世界》(Ordinary World)。
That's right. And they stayed friends all these years. His family is very good friends with our family. You know that this delights me. I know, you're very tickled by it. I am. And so the two of them came up with this story and then Lee wrote the script.
没错。这些年来他们一直保持着友谊。他的家人和我们的家人是非常好的朋友。你知道这让我很高兴。我知道，你对此感到非常开心。我是。所以他们俩想出了这个故事，然后李写了剧本。
He's now directing it. Here's what it's about. It's about three high school kids who get pranked into believing that their punk band was picked to open for Green Day on New Year's Eve in Hollywood. Yes. And so they take this crazy road trip across the country.
他现在正在执导这部电影。这是关于什么的。故事讲述了三个高中生被恶作剧，以为他们的朋克乐队被选中在除夕夜在好莱坞为绿日乐队开场。是的。于是他们进行了一场疯狂的全国公路旅行。
Yes, all the while believing that when they eventually get to LA, they're opening for Green Day. And of course, a bunch of crazy stuff happens on the road. And some of the stuff that happens on the road is based on stuff that actually happened to Green Day during their years of living in a tour van. The movie stars Mason Thames and McKenna Grace, along with a whole bunch of other folks like me and Angela.
是的，他们一直以为当他们最终到达洛杉矶时，他们要为绿日乐队开场。当然，路上发生了一堆疯狂的事情。路上发生的一些事情是基于绿日乐队在巡演车里生活那些年里真实发生过的事情。这部电影由梅森·泰晤士和麦肯娜·格瑞丝主演，还有像我和安吉拉这样的许多其他人。
It also stars Fred Armisen, Sean Gunn, and Bobby Lee. The movie features a ton of Green Day music and ends with a Green Day concert. Unfortunately, me and Angela don't have any scenes together, but we both have such fun roles. Yeah. So, you know, we got to do this table read. And I mean, how much fun was that table read, lady? So fun. I can't wait for people to see the movie. Jenna, tell them who you play.
它还由弗雷德·阿米森、肖恩·古恩和鲍比·李主演。电影里有大量的绿日乐队音乐，并以一场绿日乐队的演唱会结束。不幸的是，我和安吉拉没有对手戏，但我们都有非常有趣的角色。是的。所以，你知道，我们参加了剧本围读。我的天，那次围读太有趣了，女士！太有趣了。我迫不及待想让大家看到这部电影。珍娜，告诉他们你演谁。
OK, I'm playing Jodie. She's the mother of Tommy, who's played by Mason Thames. And she's a widowed mom who's doing her best to get by and support her family. She's a waitress. She has kind of like a rock and roll past and she's just trying to do the right thing by her kids. Right. Well, I am playing Wilma and I just love that my character has that name
好的，我演朱迪。她是汤米的母亲，汤米由梅森·泰晤士饰演。她是一位寡妇母亲，正在尽最大努力维持生计并支持她的家庭。她是一名服务员。她有一种摇滚乐的过去，她只是想为她的孩子们做正确的事。没错。而我演威尔玛，我非常喜欢我的角色有这个名字，
because my mom had a sister named Wilma who I love dearly. Your Aunt Wilma. My Aunt Wilma from Mississippi. Well, this Wilma is a loud and kind of a foul-mouthed proprietor of a rough-and-tumble Road House in the middle of Oklahoma. Y'all I was born to play this role. You? I know this woman. I know her. I have met her. I'm telling you I'm thinking about like in
因为我妈妈有一个叫威尔玛的姐妹，我非常爱她。你的威尔玛阿姨。我来自密西西比州的威尔玛阿姨。嗯，这个威尔玛是一个大嗓门、说话有点粗鲁的女人，她是俄克拉荷马州中部一家粗犷酒吧的老板。各位，我天生就是演这个角色的料。你？我认识这个女人。我认识她。我见过她。我跟你说，我在想，比如在
my hometown there's a Legion Hall. Yeah. Where you can go have an adult beverage. I know, I know her. Well, it is such a great, fun part. You are gonna shine. I can't wait for people to see you in this. And can I spoiler alert? Angela, you have been growing out your roots for this role. That is how committed you are. I am, I am.
我的家乡有一个军团大厅。是的。在那里你可以去喝杯成人饮料。我知道，我认识她。嗯，这是一个非常棒、非常有趣的角色。你会大放异彩的。我迫不及待想让大家看到你的表演。我可以剧透一下吗？安吉拉，你为了这个角色一直在留你的发根。你就是这么投入。我是，我是。
You have not been coloring your hair because- For a month, y'all. Look at me, I'm like, y'all, for a month. I just felt like Wilma probably wouldn't fuss with her hair. She's busy, she's running a bar. Yeah, she is. Yeah, but I do think she gets her nails done. I haven't shared that with you yet.
你一直没有染发，因为——整整一个月，各位。看看我，我像是在说，各位，整整一个月。我只是觉得威尔玛可能不会费心打理她的头发。她很忙，她在经营一家酒吧。是的，她是。是的，但我确实认为她会去做美甲。我还没跟你分享过这个。
Oh, okay. I do. Yeah. Because in my family, the Southern gals, they never miss their nail appointment. Everything else might be falling apart, but their nails are done. Yeah, I like. Yeah. Because in my family, the Southern gals, they never miss their nail appointment. Everything else might be falling apart, but their nails are done. Yeah.
哦，好的。我会的。是的，因为在我的家庭里，南方的姑娘们从不错过她们的美甲预约。其他一切可能都在分崩离析，但她们的美甲必须做好。是的，我喜欢。是的，因为在我的家庭里，南方的姑娘们从不错过她们的美甲预约。其他一切可能都在分崩离析，但她们的美甲必须做好。是的。
I like this choice. Yeah. Well, we had a big conversation. Does my character have a tattoo? Because of her past. Oh. And I said, she definitely has a tattoo. I think the question is,
我喜欢这个选择。是的。嗯，我们进行了一次深入的交谈。我的角色有纹身吗？因为她的过去。哦。我说，她肯定有纹身。我想问题是，
is her tattoo in a place you can see it? Oh. Because it could be somewhere that you wouldn't see I think the question is, is her tattoo in a place you can see it? Oh. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Because it could be somewhere that you wouldn't see while she's just at home having coffee. What did you decide? She has several in places that you can see and not see. Oh. So there you go.
她的纹身在你能看到的地方吗？哦。因为它可能在某个你看不见的地方。我想问题是，她的纹身在你能看到的地方吗？哦。嗯哼。嗯哼。因为它可能在某个你看不见的地方，而她只是在家里喝咖啡。你决定了什么？她有几个纹身，有的在你能看到的地方，有的在看不见的地方。哦。所以就是这样。
That's what we went with. Okay. All right. So we're sharing this with you because we are off this week. We are shooting the movie. We're in Oklahoma. We are. So today we wanted to bring you something
这就是我们最终决定的。好的。好的。所以我们分享这个是因为我们这周休息。我们正在拍摄这部电影。我们在俄克拉荷马州。我们确实在。所以今天我们想带给你一些
that truly helped both of us so much as we kicked off 2025. Yes, it is Kendra Adachi, AKA The Lazy Genius. It's episode 399 titled, It's a New Year. Let's name what's working. Yeah, so for some context, as 2024 was wrapping up, Ange and I sat down and we talked about what do we want for the new year for office ladies? You know, this is that time of year where you
真正对我们俩在开启2025年时非常有帮助的东西。是的，她是肯德拉·阿达奇，也就是“懒人天才”。这是第399集，标题是《新的一年，让我们列出哪些是有效的》。是的，为了提供一些背景，当2024年即将结束时，安吉和我坐下来谈论我们对《办公室女士》新的一年有什么期待。你知道，这是一年中的这个时候，你
Reflect. You reflect. You set goals. That's right. And we both had some of the same shared goals for how we wanted our podcast workflow to go. And we were in this sort of reevaluating mindset. And then on January 1st, this episode of Kendra's dropped and I listened to it and I immediately
反思。你反思。你设定目标。没错。我们俩对于我们希望播客工作流程如何进行有一些共同的目标。我们当时处于一种重新评估的心态。然后在1月1日，肯德拉的这一集发布了，我听了之后立刻
texted Ange about it. I was like, this is what we're doing. Angela, I need you to hear Kendra's approach to this conversation that we had already started, but she frames it in such a delicious way. I know. Kendra is so good at this. She offers up such an accessible way
给安吉发了短信。我说，这就是我们要做的。安吉拉，我需要你听听肯德拉对我们已经开始的这个对话的处理方式，但她以一种非常美妙的方式表达了出来。我知道。肯德拉在这方面太棒了。她提供了一种非常容易理解的方式
to think about what is working for you, which in turn makes you see areas that could use some attention. She has three rules, three questions, and three categories to help you ask yourself what's working in your life? And lady, I loved that. I loved coming from a place of positivity rather than negativity.
来思考什么对你有效，这反过来让你看到哪些领域需要关注。她有三个规则、三个问题和三个类别，可以帮助你问自己生活中哪些是有效的？女士，我喜欢这个。我喜欢从积极的角度而不是消极的角度出发。
And now our office ladies team keeps using this phrase, what's working? What is working? Yes, this has totally crept into our conversations during our team meetings. And using this, we have created new strategies to manage our workload, we've created new routines, it has been great.
现在我们的《办公室女士》团队一直在使用这个短语，“哪些是有效的？”什么才是有效的？是的，这已经完全渗透到我们团队会议的对话中了。通过使用这个方法，我们创造了管理工作量的新策略，我们创造了新的日常习惯，这太棒了。
And we're using it at work, but it really can apply to every aspect of your life. So to relationships or maybe just even the rooms in your house. After I listened to this episode, I walked through my house and I would look at a room and be like, what's working here? Yeah. And that simple question helped me appreciate this little caddy that I bought to hold pins and pencils and scissors. It was just like
我们正在工作中应用它，但它确实可以应用于你生活的方方面面。比如人际关系，或者甚至是你家里的房间。听完这一集后，我在家里走了一圈，看着一个房间，心想，这里什么东西是有效的？是的。那个简单的问题帮助我欣赏了我买的那个用来放笔、铅笔和剪刀的小收纳盒。它就像
in that little nook in my kitchen where all the random clutter goes to pile up. Yeah. Well guess what it's not piled up anymore it's in a little caddy and it's working for me and that small thing makes me happy. I love that. But that's just such a small little thing but when you look around and see what's working it makes you want to do it to the other rooms of your house. It's like this wonderful domino effect or to your relationships or to your workflow. It's like okay well this one thing is working how can I make the rest of it work for me as well? Yes so So I have to eat a pretty specific diet because
在我厨房里那个堆满杂物的小角落里。是的。好吧，猜猜怎么着，它不再堆满了，它在小收纳盒里，这对我来说很有效，那件小事让我很开心。我喜欢这个。但这只是一件很小的事情，但当你环顾四周看看什么东西是有效的时候，它会让你想在家里其他房间也这样做。这就像这种美妙的多米诺骨牌效应，或者对你的关系，或者对你的工作流程。就像，好吧，这一件事是有效的，我怎样才能让剩下的部分也为我所用呢？是的，所以我必须遵循非常具体的饮食，因为
of the cancer medicines that I'm taking. I have to eat like high protein, lots of fruits and vegetables, high fiber, low sugar. In fact, if I don't eat this diet, sometimes I don't feel well. Like it has a direct impact on how I feel in the day. And I was getting really overwhelmed with meal prep. Like mentally. Like mentally figuring out how
我正在服用的癌症药物。我必须吃高蛋白、大量水果和蔬菜、高纤维、低糖的食物。事实上，如果我不吃这种饮食，有时我会感觉不舒服。它对我一天的感觉有直接影响。我被备餐搞得不知所措。从心理上讲。从心理上弄清楚如何
every meal was gonna fit into this very specific box was exhausting. But I did not have the luxury of being lazy about this. Right. I had to do it. So I used her philosophy. I asked myself to look at each meal from the framework of what was already working. Because in the moment, it felt like nothing was working. Right. But actually, when I looked at it, my breakfast is working. It's easy.
让每一顿饭都符合这个非常具体的框架是令人筋疲力尽的。但我没有奢侈到在这件事上偷懒。没错。我必须这样做。所以我用了她的哲学。我要求自己从“什么已经有效”的框架来看待每一顿饭。因为在那一刻，感觉好像什么都不起作用。没错。但实际上，当我审视它时，我的早餐是有效的。它很简单。
I eat the same thing every day. It's great. My dinners were working because I was already planning and prepping family meals that pretty much met my criteria. So really, the only thing that wasn't working was my lunch. And Kendra suggests that you ask yourself if you can apply what is working about one routine to your routine that is not working.
我每天吃同样的东西。这很好。我的晚餐是有效的，因为我已经在计划和准备基本符合我标准的家庭餐了。所以实际上，唯一无效的就是我的午餐。肯德拉建议你问自己，是否可以将一个日常习惯中有效的部分应用到你无效的日常习惯中。
So when I dug deeper, I was like, well, why is breakfast working? And it's pretty much because I eat the same thing and I don't care. I don't care that I eat the same breakfast. So I tried to apply that to my lunches. I picked three lunches that I could prepare easily, quickly, and that I could make in batches of like three to four days worth. So my three lunches now are soup, chili, or tuna salad. Done.
所以当我深入挖掘时，我想，嗯，为什么早餐是有效的？这主要是因为我吃同样的东西，而且我不在乎。我不在乎我每天吃同样的早餐。所以我试着把它应用到我的午餐上。我选了三种我可以轻松、快速准备，并且可以一次做三到四天份量的午餐。所以我现在的三顿午餐是汤、辣椒酱或金枪鱼沙拉。搞定。
They have all the stuff in them that I'm supposed to eat. And now I'm not making a new lunch every single day. And you're not stressed about it. No, and it's working. Now all three of my meals are working. That's great. I know. It's such a simple question.
它们里面有我应该吃的所有东西。现在我不用每天做新的午餐了。而且你也不用为此感到压力了。不，而且它很有效。现在我的三顿饭都很有效。那太棒了。我知道。这是一个如此简单的问题。
And I think that's why it's so easy to act on. Yes. Well we hope you love this episode as much as we did. It's just such a great way to start the new year. And just know we are having a good time in Oklahoma. We can't wait to tell you about it. Exactly. But now here is the Lazy Genius episode. It's a new year. Let's name what's working. Hey there, you're listening to the Lazy Genius podcast. I'm Kendra Adachi and I'm here to help you be a genius about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. Today is episode 399. It's a new year. Let's name what's working. Today is the first Monday of January, which might
我认为这就是为什么它很容易付诸行动的原因。是的。好吧，我们希望你像我们一样喜欢这一集。这真是开启新的一年的好方法。要知道我们在俄克拉荷马州玩得很开心。我们迫不及待想告诉你关于它的事。没错。但现在，这是“懒人天才”的一集。新的一年，让我们列出哪些是有效的。嘿，你正在收听“懒人天才”播客。我是肯德拉·阿达奇，我在这里帮助你成为重要事情的天才，而在不重要的事情上做个懒人。今天是第399集。新的一年，让我们列出哪些是有效的。今天是1月的第一个星期一，这可能
feel any number of ways for you, but just in case you have scattered, oh no, Today is the first Monday of January which might feel any number of ways for you but just in case you have scattered oh no it's the first Monday of January energy or if you need a reminder that you don't have to chase greatness at the gate this episode is for you. The beginning of the year or the beginning of anything often has us rethinking our routines and rhythms and systems and choices to see if there's anything we want to change. That path is well and good and likely necessary on occasion. I love identifying small problems, applying small solutions, adjusting over time, and then slowly building rhythms and systems that work from those small decisions. It's a slower go compared to big black trash bag energy
对你来说有各种各样的感觉，但以防万一你有那种分散的，哦不，今天是1月的第一个星期一，或者如果你需要提醒自己不必在起跑线上就追求伟大，这一集就是为你准备的。一年的开始或任何事情的开始，往往让我们重新思考我们的日常习惯、节奏、系统和选择，看看是否有我们想要改变的地方。那条路很好，而且偶尔可能是必要的。我喜欢识别小问题，应用小解决方案，随着时间的推移进行调整，然后慢慢建立起基于这些小决定的节奏和系统。与那种“黑色大垃圾袋”式的能量相比，这是一个更缓慢的过程，
where you just start everything over, but it lasts longer because you don't keep starting everything over. So before you start to put on your problem-solving glasses, utilizing that new year January energy to make everything fresh and ready to begin, let's name what's working. Okay. I have three rules, three questions, and three categories to help you think this through. You can take whatever helps and just leave the rest. You can be as detailed as you want and write stuff down, or you can just think about it in your head, decide that this particular thing is working really well,
你只是把一切都重新开始，但它持续的时间更长，因为你不会一直重新开始。所以在你开始戴上解决问题的眼镜，利用新的一年1月的能量让一切焕然一新并准备开始之前，让我们列出哪些是有效的。好的。我有三个规则、三个问题和三个类别来帮助你思考这个问题。你可以拿走任何有帮助的东西，剩下的就留着。你可以尽可能详细地写下来，或者你也可以只在脑子里想一想，决定这件特定的事情非常有效，
high five yourself and move on. You use the content in this episode in whatever combination and intensity you want. So three rules, three questions, three categories. Let's start with the three rules. Rule number one, when you're naming what's working, the smaller the better. Naming small things that are working in your life are weirdly powerful. You might try and say breakfast is working pretty well, but the specificity and smallness of having muffins in the freezer and protein yogurt drinks in the fridge are working super well for everybody.
给自己一个击掌，然后继续前进。你可以以任何你想要的组合和强度使用这一集的内容。所以三个规则，三个问题，三个类别。让我们从三个规则开始。规则一，当你列出哪些是有效的时，越小越好。列出你生活中有效的小事情具有不可思议的力量。你可能会试着说早餐效果不错，但冷冻室里有松饼，冰箱里有蛋白酸奶饮料，这种具体性和微小性对每个人来说都非常有效。
The smaller the thing, the greater the opportunity for you to truly understand what is working. You can see the particular moving parts of the thing rather than just like a large ambiguous category. So rule number one, the smaller, the better. Rule number two, when you're naming what's working, working doesn't mean perfect. We're naming what's working. We're not naming what's perfect. Very little is and very little will be. Perfect is relative and arbitrary anyway. So as you assess and decide what's working in your life, be kind about that word. Working doesn't mean and decide what's working in your life, be kind about that word.
事情越小，你真正理解什么才是有效的机会就越大。你可以看到事情的具体组成部分，而不是像一个大的模糊类别。所以规则一，越小越好。规则二，当你列出哪些是有效的时，有效并不意味着完美。我们列出的是有效的。我们不是在列出完美的。很少有东西是完美的，也很少有东西会是完美的。完美本身就是相对的和武断的。所以当你评估并决定你生活中什么有效时，对那个词要宽容一点。有效并不意味着
Working doesn't mean perfect. It's working. It might be a little janky and how it's working, but it's working. Don't be so hard on yourself. Rule number three, when you're naming what's working, now isn't forever. What's working now might not and likely won't work forever. That can swing both ways. You can have something you love that's working now might not and likely won't work forever. That can swing both ways. You can have something you love that's working now. And also it's good to remember that we have to hold these things with an open hand. It might not work forever,
完美。它是有效的。它在运作方式上可能有点笨拙，但它是有效的。不要对自己太苛刻。规则三，当你列出哪些是有效的时，现在并不代表永远。现在有效的东西可能不会，而且很可能不会永远有效。这可以双向摆动。你可能有一些你喜欢的东西，现在有效。而且也要记住，我们必须以开放的心态对待这些事情。它可能不会永远有效，
but we'll enjoy it now while it does. Or if you do have something that's working, but it's connected to something in your season of life that's frustrating to you and you wish it were different. That's okay. Now isn't forever. It probably won't always be this way. So try not to resent where you are.
但我们现在享受它。或者，如果你确实有一些有效的东西，但它与你生活中让你沮丧的某个阶段有关，你希望它有所不同。没关系。现在并不代表永远。它可能不会永远这样。所以尽量不要怨恨你所处的位置。
Either way, now isn't forever. So those are your three rules as you move into naming what's working. The smaller, the better. Working doesn't mean perfect and now isn't forever. With that perspective in mind, let's move to the three questions you can ask to help you narrow your focus on what specifically is working in the categories that we'll name in a minute. The three questions are, what problem does this solve? What do I like about this? And how does this make me feel like myself? First, what problem does this solve?
无论哪种方式，现在并不代表永远。所以这就是你进入列出哪些是有效的过程时的三个规则。越小越好。有效并不意味着完美，现在并不代表永远。考虑到这种观点，让我们转向三个问题，你可以问自己这些问题，以帮助你缩小对我们稍后将命名的类别中什么具体是有效的关注。这三个问题是，这解决了什么问题？我喜欢它的什么？这怎么让我感觉像我自己？首先，这解决了什么问题？
When you're looking at an area of your life and you're identifying what's working there, naming the solved problem could be super beneficial. You know, maybe it's solving a problem that you've had for a long time and naming that the problem is solved is worth celebrating. Maybe it's solving a problem that you're spotting in other places. So seeing the success of your solution in one place, it might help you get ideas for another place. Essentially, like what problem does this thing that's working solve for you. We have a drink spinner on our counter. It's just a wooden
当你审视你生活的某个领域并确定什么在那里有效时，列出已解决的问题可能非常有益。你知道，也许它解决了一个你长期存在的问题，而列出那个问题已解决是值得庆祝的。也许它解决了一个你在其他地方发现的问题。所以看到你的解决方案在一个地方的成功，它可能会帮助你为另一个地方获得灵感。本质上，这个有效的东西为你解决了什么问题。我们的柜台上有一个饮料旋转架。它只是一个木制的
lazy Susan on the edge of our kitchen island. And I put it there years ago to try and solve the small problem of glasses and water bottles being all over the house. Kids would leave bottles and cups on random surfaces. They'd be in different places in the kitchen, which made the kitchen feel visually cluttered. It was a small problem, but an annoying one. So I thought that a great way to maybe solve this small problem would be with a small solution of one place where the cups and water bottles go. They have a holding pen and unless they're being used, that's where they live altogether. It's like one big beverage family. The drink spinner works beautifully now. It took a while for kids to remember, but it has become second nature to everyone in our house. Your cups
懒人转盘，放在我们厨房岛的边缘。我几年前把它放在那里，试图解决杯子和水瓶到处都是的小问题。孩子们会把瓶子和杯子留在随机的表面上。它们会出现在厨房的不同地方，这让厨房在视觉上感觉杂乱。这是一个小问题，但很烦人。所以我认为解决这个小问题的一个好方法可能是一个小解决方案，即杯子和水瓶去的一个地方。它们有一个存放处，除非正在使用，否则它们就住在一起。这就像一个大家庭。饮料旋转架现在工作得很好。孩子们花了一段时间才记住，但它已经成为我们家里每个人的第二天性。你的杯子
and water bottles, they live on the drink spinner. End of story. If I walked into my kitchen and I noticed that drink spinner as I'm, as I'm looking at my life and being like, you know what, what's working? Let's celebrate what's working. I would say this is working because it's all the problem of keeping track of cups, but also of my silent rage about seeing cups everywhere. Let's say I have silent rage about something else that seems to live all over the house. Noticing how the drink spinner is working
和水瓶，它们住在饮料旋转架上。故事结束。如果我走进厨房，注意到那个饮料旋转架，当我审视我的生活并心想，你知道吗，什么东西是有效的？让我们庆祝什么东西是有效的。我会说这是有效的，因为它解决了跟踪杯子的问题，也解决了看到杯子到处都是时我的无声愤怒。假设我对生活在房子各处的其他东西有无声的愤怒。注意到饮料旋转架是如何工作的
helps me recognize a small solution for a separate small problem. So as you're identifying what's working, that's the first specific question to help you see why it does. What problem does this solve? This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, you often hear about like the red flags to look for in a relationship.
帮助我识别出一个单独小问题的微小解决方案。所以当你确定什么东西是有效的时候，这是帮助你看到它为什么有效的第一个具体问题。这解决了什么问题？本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，你经常听到关于人际关系中需要注意的红旗。
But what if, what if we like changed that focus and started making a list of the green flags that we were looking for in friends and partners? You know, like more like instead of framing it, here's what I'm avoiding, be like, here's what I want to run toward. OK. Well, if you're not sure what your list of green flags is, therapy can help you identify them. And you know, BetterHelp is fully online,
但是如果，如果我们改变那种焦点，开始列出我们在朋友和伴侣身上寻找的绿旗清单呢？你知道，就像与其把它框定为，这是我正在避免的，不如说，这是我想要奔向的。好的。好吧，如果你不确定你的绿旗清单是什么，治疗可以帮助你识别它们。而且你知道，BetterHelp完全在线，
making therapy affordable and convenient, serving over 5 million people worldwide. You can access a diverse network of more than 30,000 credentialed therapists with a wide range of specialties. You can also switch therapists at any time at no extra cost. Discover your relationship green flags with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. That's Better Help, H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies.
使治疗变得负担得起且方便，为全球超过500万人提供服务。你可以访问一个拥有超过30,000名具有广泛专业领域的认证治疗师的多样化网络。你也可以随时免费更换治疗师。用BetterHelp发现你的人际关系绿旗。今天访问betterhelp.com/office ladies，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是Better Help, H-E-L-P点com斜杠office ladies。
What happens when fear and prejudice are ignited by the hysteria of war? I'm Sharon McMing, host of Here's Where It Gets Interesting. I answer that question in my new series, 9066, and dig into the stories of more than 120,000 people of Japanese ancestry who were imprisoned in the United States during World War II. Find here's where it gets interesting in the free Odyssey app and everywhere you get your podcasts. Before we get into the second question, let me remind you again that you don't have to be precious or orderly or organized with these questions.
当恐惧和偏见被战争的歇斯底里点燃时会发生什么？我是莎伦·麦克明，是《这就是变得有趣的地方》的主持人。我在我的新系列《9066》中回答了这个问题，并深入挖掘了二战期间在美国被监禁的超过12万名日本血统的人的故事。在免费的Odyssey应用程序和你获取播客的任何地方找到《这就是变得有趣的地方》。在我们进入第二个问题之前，让我再次提醒你，你不需要对这些问题过于珍视、有序或有条理。
You don't even have to try to answer any of them. They're more for those of you who need a little clarity and trying to identify what's working. And we do this anyway because we care about today. We care about who we are right now in this life we live in. We care about remembering that we do actually have things in life that are working. We can find our way out of early January discouragement of all we wanna change.
你甚至不需要尝试回答其中任何一个。它们更多是为那些需要一点清晰度并试图确定什么东西是有效的人准备的。我们这样做是因为我们关心今天。我们关心我们现在在这个我们生活的生命中是谁。我们关心记住我们生活中确实有有效的东西。我们可以找到摆脱1月初沮丧情绪的方法，摆脱所有我们想要改变的东西。
Instead, we're gonna name what's working. So use these questions if they help. All right, the second question you might ask is, what do I like about this? Let's keep joy and pleasure and ease in mind here. What do you like about this thing that's working? Taking a lunch break every day works so well for me because it solves the problem of not always slowing down on purpose. What do I like about it? Well, I like food. So there's that. It's nice that it's lunchtime. But I also like that there are no
相反，我们要列出哪些是有效的。所以如果这些问题有帮助，就使用它们。好的，你可能会问的第二个问题是，我喜欢它的什么？在这里保持快乐、愉悦和轻松的心态。你喜欢这个有效的东西的什么？每天休息吃午饭对我来说非常有效，因为它解决了没有总是刻意放慢速度的问题。我喜欢它的什么？嗯，我喜欢食物。所以就是这样。午餐时间很好。但我还喜欢的是，对于我休息的那个午餐时间，没有任何
expectations for me for that lunch hour that I take. I can eat and watch a show or eat and read a book or eat and sit on my porch and silence for a few minutes before going inside to watch a show or read a book. I like that I can do what I need to do in the moment. But whatever I choose is genuinely enjoyable to me. Name what you like about a thing that's working. Put some meat on its bones as to why. It gives it more staying power and personal enjoyment that way.
对我的期望。我可以吃东西看节目，或者吃东西看书，或者吃东西坐在门廊上安静几分钟，然后再进去看节目或看书。我喜欢我可以在那一刻做我需要做的事情。但我选择的任何东西对我来说都是真正令人愉快的。列出你喜欢一个有效东西的什么。说明为什么，给它加点料。这样它就有了更强的持久力和个人享受。
Remember, perspective really matters here. And a third question you might ask to help you understand what's working is, how does this make me feel like myself? Not everything might, and that's fine. But in order to slowly nurture an integrated life that is rooted in your own humanity and what matters most to you in your season, it's not a ridiculous thing to consider how your decisions and rhythms
记住，观点在这里真的很重要。你可能会问的第三个问题来帮助你理解什么东西是有效的，那就是，这怎么让我感觉像我自己？并非所有东西都可能，这没关系。但为了慢慢培养一种植根于你自身人性以及在你这个阶段对你最重要的东西的整合生活，考虑你的决定和节奏
and systems make you feel like yourself. You might say this thing makes me feel calm, which keeps me from going outside of myself in a rage. This thing makes me feel creative, even though I'm doing something mundane, because I'm doing it in a unique way that's working for me. You see what I mean? Also, a lot of you often ask me how to figure out
以及系统如何让你感觉像你自己，这并不是一件荒谬的事情。你可能会说这东西让我感到平静，这让我不会因为愤怒而失去自我。这东西让我感到有创造力，即使我正在做一些平凡的事情，因为我正在以一种对我有效且独特的方式去做。你明白我的意思吗？此外，你们很多人经常问我如何弄清楚
what makes you feel like yourself. Sometimes I think we put too much pressure on that question or on the feeling. When something makes you feel like yourself? Sometimes I think we put too much pressure on that question or on the feeling. When something makes you feel like yourself, it might not be the most happy fulfilled unicorns and rainbows version of yourself. You might feel like yourself because of the house rule, no piles on the kitchen island. Visual clutter might take you out of yourself. So visual tidiness, especially in commonly used spaces like the kitchen, makes you feel more out of yourself. So visual tidiness, especially in commonly used spaces like the kitchen, makes you feel more connected to yourself. It
什么让你感觉像你自己。有时我认为我们对那个问题或那种感觉施加了太大的压力。当某件事让你感觉像你自己时？有时我认为我们对那个问题或那种感觉施加了太大的压力。当某件事让你感觉像你自己时，它可能不是最快乐、最满足、彩虹般的你自己。你可能因为家规而感觉像你自己，比如厨房岛上没有堆积物。视觉杂乱可能会让你失去自我。所以视觉整洁，特别是在厨房等常用空间，让你感觉更脱离自我。所以视觉整洁，特别是在厨房等常用空间，让你感觉更
doesn't have to be technicolor to count. So three questions that could help give a little insight into why something is working are what problem is this solving? What do I like about this? And how does this make me feel like myself? Now you might be ready to start naming this in your life, but you might feel a little scattershot about it. You know, you're a pinball within the machine of your life, just like freely associating what's working as one idea pings into another.
与自己连接。它不需要是彩色电影才能算数。所以三个问题可以帮助深入了解为什么某件事是有效的，它们是：这解决了什么问题？我喜欢它的什么？这怎么让我感觉像我自己？现在你可能准备好开始在你的生活中列出这些了，但你可能会觉得有点杂乱无章。你知道，你是你生活机器里的弹球，只是自由联想什么东西是有效的，一个想法撞向另一个想法。
And that's honestly a great way to do it. This does not have to be a detailed homework assignment. It's ultimately, it's just a posture. Just name what's working. Look for what's working. Don't focus so hard on what's not. So ping away. If you want to ping, ping.
老实说，这是一种很好的做法。这不需要是一份详细的家庭作业。归根结底，这只是一种姿态。只需列出哪些是有效的。寻找哪些是有效的。不要太专注于哪些是无效的。所以尽情联想吧。如果你想联想，就联想吧。
Now if you'd like to be a bit more methodical or if you would enjoy a new way of looking at the areas in your life so you don't miss anything even though you totally well. Here are three categories that you could consider time of day, regular events and rooms in your house. Now these are broad on purpose. There's simply doors you can walk through to kind of help you notice and narrow your focus on what you would like to notice. So category one, the time of day, all right. Mornings mid morning. If you're home with tiny humans after school, transitioning from work to home, dinner, bedtime routine, evenings, et cetera, et cetera. Start your thinking at one time of day and just look around.
现在，如果你想更系统一点，或者如果你喜欢一种新的方式来看待你生活中的领域，这样你就不会错过任何东西，即使你完全会错过。这里有三个类别你可以考虑：一天中的时间、常规事件和家里的房间。这些类别是故意设定的很宽泛。它们只是你可以穿过的门，以帮助你注意到并缩小你想要注意的焦点。所以类别一，一天中的时间，好的。早晨、上午。如果你和年幼的孩子在家，放学后，从工作过渡到家庭，晚餐，睡前习惯，晚上等等。从一天中的某个时间开始你的思考，环顾四周。
You can even live in it like tomorrow morning. Pay attention to what's working. What do you see that solving a problem? What do you see that you like? What do you see that makes you feel like yourself or make someone else in your home feel like themselves? Being present at a certain time of day or using your imagination and memory for that particular time of day, it can help you notice what's working. Category two, regular events. What tasks or events or activities happen on a regular basis? Meals. Meals are very regular. Carpool or commuting, regular meetings, decide once gatherings like messaging friends while you're waiting for your groceries to be loaded into your car or like actually going grocery shopping with a friend every Tuesday or whatever it is. Look on your calendar if you use one or just pay attention to the regular things
你甚至可以像明天早上那样生活在其中。注意什么东西是有效的。你看到了什么解决了问题？你看到了什么你喜欢的？你看到了什么让你感觉像你自己，或者让你家里其他人感觉像他们自己？在一天中的某个特定时间保持在场，或者利用你的想象力和记忆力来处理那个特定的时间，它可以帮助你注意到什么东西是有效的。类别二，常规事件。什么任务、事件或活动是定期发生的？用餐。用餐非常规律。拼车或通勤，定期会议，决定一次聚会，比如当你等待杂货装进车里时给朋友发信息，或者像每周二和朋友一起去买杂货，或者无论它是什么。如果你使用日历，看看你的日历，或者只是注意生活中的常规事情
in life and notice what's working in there. And then category three is rooms in your house or rooms in your life. Different rooms have different functions. So literally walking into a room in your home, it can help you notice what's working there. There could be decorating decisions or cozy decisions that make you very happy. Maybe you think of tasks that are often done in that particular room. You know, what about cleaning that specific room? Walk into a room in your house, pause, and ask yourself, what's working in here? What happens in here that's working? What do I like about this room?
并注意其中什么东西是有效的。然后类别三是你家里的房间或你生活中的房间。不同的房间有不同的功能。所以字面上走进你家里的一个房间，它可以帮助你注意到什么东西是有效的。可能有装饰决定或舒适的决定让你非常开心。也许你会想到经常在那个特定房间完成的任务。你知道，打扫那个特定的房间怎么样？走进你家里的一个房间，停下来，问自己，这里什么东西是有效的？这里发生了什么东西是有效的？我喜欢这个房间的什么？
What do I like about what happens in this room? These can be physical rooms in your own home, but they can also be like your car or your desk at work or any physical space you spend time in. What's working here? So those are the three rules, three questions and three categories. The three rules are the smaller the better,
我喜欢在这个房间里发生的事情的什么？这些可以是你自己家里的物理房间，但它们也可以是你的车、你在工作时的办公桌或任何你花时间的物理空间。这里什么东西是有效的？所以这就是三个规则、三个问题和三个类别。三个规则是越小越好，
working doesn't mean perfect and now isn't forever. When you're naming what's working, keep those three things in mind. The three questions that might help you identify why something is working are what problem is this solving? What do I like about this? And how does this make me feel like myself? And then the three categories
有效并不意味着完美，现在并不代表永远。当你列出哪些是有效的时，请记住这三件事。可能帮助你确定为什么某件事是有效的三个问题是：这解决了什么问题？我喜欢它的什么？这怎么让我感觉像我自己？然后是三个类别
that could help you narrow your focus are times of day, regular events, and rooms in your home and life. So what do you do now? The point of these ideas is not to fix things. In fact, it's the opposite. We are noticing what's working so that we stop the spin out of thinking that everything isn't. This time of year has us in our heads about fresh starts and big changes. And again, while those are totally fine, begin where you are. Begin with what's working. Celebrate it. Notice it. So often when we see how many things might be working,
可以帮助你缩小焦点的类别是：一天中的时间、常规事件以及你家和生活中的房间。那么你现在该做什么？这些想法的重点不是为了修复事情。事实上，恰恰相反。我们正在注意到什么东西是有效的，这样我们就停止了认为一切都不起作用的恶性循环。一年中的这个时候让我们在脑子里思考新的开始和大的改变。再说一次，虽然这些完全没问题，但从你所在的地方开始。从有效的地方开始。庆祝它。注意到它。通常当我们看到有多少事情可能是有效的时候，
we calm down a little about what isn't. So even though you could, in theory, go through your entire life with the three rules in mind and ask all three of those questions, I don't think that's necessary. That's not starting small anyway. Pay attention to the area of your life that has the biggest pull for you to make it better. Stay in that place and instead name what's working. Be where you are. Be kind about the things already in place. Refresh your perspective on the things in your life that do in fact solve your problems. Things that you like that make you feel like yourself. Be who you are and where you are today. You're
我们对那些无效的事情就会冷静一点。所以即使你理论上可以带着这三个规则审视你的整个生活并问所有这三个问题，我不认为那是必要的。那也不是从小事做起。注意你生活中最吸引你想要改进的领域。留在那个地方，转而列出哪些是有效的。身处你所在的地方。对已经到位的事情要宽容。刷新你对生活中确实能解决你问题的那些事情的看法。你喜欢的、让你感觉像你自己的事情。做你自己，就在你今天所在的地方。你
doing great. If you'd like a peek into what's working for me on a really practical level, episode 349 is called 10 Small Changes I'm Glad I Made. And then episode 366 is 20 Helpful Decisions I Keep Repeating. Those are practical, practical lists of what's working in my life, and many of them have been working for years. The tiny solutions, the small changes, the decisions you make once that still work, those are the parts of a steady system that you don't have to keep starting over on. So be where you are. Notice what's happening today. Celebrate the changes you've made.
做得很好。如果你想看看在非常实际的层面上什么对我有效，第349集叫《我很高兴我做的10个小改变》。然后第366集是《我不断重复的20个有益决定》。那些是关于我生活中什么有效的实际清单，其中许多已经有效多年了。微小的解决方案、小的改变、你做一次就一直有效的决定，这些都是稳定系统的一部分，你不需要一直重新开始。所以身处你所在的地方。注意今天发生了什么。庆祝你所做的改变。
The smaller, the better. Working doesn't mean perfect and now isn't forever. That's how we start a new year. Let's name what's working. One thing I know a lot of you do at the end of December and the beginning of January is to reread the Lazy Genius way. I mentioned that last week. I love that y'all do that. It's something that works for you and it's humbling and fun for me. So thank you.
越小越好。有效并不意味着完美，现在并不代表永远。这就是我们开启新的一年的方式。让我们列出哪些是有效的。我知道你们很多人在12月底和1月初做的一件事是重读《懒人天才之道》。我上周提到了这一点。我喜欢你们这样做。这是对你有效的事情，对我来说既谦卑又有趣。所以谢谢你们。
Having a refresher on the 13 lazy genius principles as you're going into a new year, it really is helpful. If you have never read my first book, The Lazy Genius Way, it dedicates a chapter to each of the 13 lazy genius principles. Decide once, start small, ask the magic question, live in the season, build the right routines, set house rules, put everything in its place, let people in, batch it, essentialize, go in the right order, and be kind to yourself. It's the Little Engine That Could book, just plugging along, still selling copies over four years later. If you've never read it, but you have thought about it, now is a really
在进入新的一年时回顾这13个懒人天才原则，真的很有帮助。如果你从未读过我的第一本书《懒人天才之道》，它为这13个懒人天才原则中的每一个都专门写了一章。决定一次、从小事做起、问神奇问题、活在当下、建立正确的日常习惯、设定家规、把一切放在原位、让人们进来、批量处理、精简、按正确的顺序进行，并善待自己。它是《小火车头》那本书，只是在坚持，四年多后仍在销售。如果你从未读过它，但你考虑过，现在是一个非常
good time to do it. I read the audiobook so if that's more your speed to listen as you're like taking down holiday decorations or going for wintry walks or trying to keep your children entertained before school goes back, give it a shot. I think you'll enjoy it. This is also an excellent time of year to read the plan. It's all about compassionate time management, helping you rewire your thinking from optimization and greatness and making the most out of your time to just being a grounded whole person right where you are. Being okay with some things being great and others just being mid. It's practical,
好的时间去做。我读了有声书，所以如果那是你更喜欢的速度，比如你在拆除节日装饰、去冬日散步或试图在学校开学前让你的孩子保持娱乐时听，试一试。我想你会喜欢的。这也是一年中阅读《计划》的绝佳时间。它完全关于富有同情心的时间管理，帮助你从优化、伟大和充分利用你的时间，重新连接你的思维，转变为就在你所在的地方做一个脚踏实地的完整的人。接受有些事情很棒，而另一些事情只是平庸。它是实际的、
permission-giving and full of pep talks to get you through any January chaos you might experience. I read that audiobook too. But I think for the plan, you'll be so glad you have the physical copy. So thanks for reading my books and supporting my work y'all. It means a lot. Okay, before we go, let's celebrate the lazy genius of the week. This week, it's Ashley Eidsen
给予许可的，并且充满了鼓励的话，让你度过你可能经历的任何1月混乱。我也读了那本有声书。但我认为对于《计划》，你会很高兴拥有实体书。所以谢谢你们阅读我的书并支持我的工作。这意义重大。好的，在我们走之前，让我们庆祝一下本周的懒人天才。本周是阿什利·艾德森，
with a super interesting approach to holiday gift giving that actually matters a little right now at the beginning of the year. Ashley writes every year, my husband and I save up our credit card rewards across a few different cards and we don't spend them all year. Then when it is Christmas time, the amount we have in rewards is our budget. We know how many gifts we need to buy each year.
她有一种非常有趣的节日送礼方法，这在年初确实有点重要。阿什利写道，每年，我和我丈夫都会在几张不同的卡片上存下我们的信用卡奖励，我们一年都不花。然后当圣诞节到来时，我们拥有的奖励金额就是我们的预算。我们知道每年我们需要买多少礼物。
We know how much we have and that's how we divide it up. Some years we've had to make some decisions like not getting gifts for every coworker in the office, but it always seems to work out where the people we wanna give gifts to comes very close to our total. Last year we had a little bit higher rewards total and we were able to buy some presents for ourselves
我们知道自己有多少预算，然后就按这个来分配。有些年份我们不得不做出一些决定，比如不给办公室里的每一位同事都买礼物，但最终总能凑巧，我们想送礼的对象所需的花费和我们的总预算非常接近。去年我们的奖励总额稍微多了一点，所以除了购买其他所有东西之外，我们还能给自己买些礼物。
at the end of the year on top of everything else we purchased. Hope this helps someone else enjoy the holiday season without stressing about breaking the bank with the regular monthly bills and expenses. What a fantastic idea this is. Can you see why I wanted to share this one like right now at the start of the year? This could be a fantastic approach for a lot of us when it comes to holiday budgets. The rewards just do it for you. Love how practical and helpful this is. So thank you for sharing Ashley and congratulations on being the lazy genius of the week. This episode is hosted by me, Kendra Adachi, an executive produced by
在年底的时候，除了我们购买的其他所有东西之外。希望这能帮助其他人享受节日季，而不必担心因为常规的月度账单和开支而入不敷出。这真是一个绝妙的主意。你能明白为什么我想在年初的时候就分享这个吗？对于我们很多人来说，这在制定节日预算时可能是一个非常棒的方法。奖励机制就能帮你搞定。我非常喜欢这种既实用又有帮助的方法。所以谢谢你的分享，Ashley，也恭喜你成为本周的“懒人天才”。本期节目由我，Kendra Adachi主持，执行制片人是
Kendra Adachi, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. The lazy genius podcast is enthusiastically part of the office ladies network. Special thanks to Leah Jarvis for weekly production. Thanks y'all for listening and until next time, be a genius about the things that matter and lazy about the things that don't. I'm Kendra and I'll see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Kendra Adachi、Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey。《懒人天才》播客是Office Ladies网络的一部分。特别感谢Leah Jarvis的每周制作。感谢大家的收听，下次见，在重要的事情上做个天才，在不重要的事情上做个懒人。我是Kendra，我们下周见。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。